عقوبات امريكيه ضد الرجل اعمال تركي مقرب
من الرئيس اردوغان بتهمه تسهيل بيع النفط
وغسل الاموال لصالح الحرس الثوري الايراني
الخزانه الامريكيه المنوط بها فرد
العقوبات اوضحت في بيان لها ان العقوبات
تاتي بسبب دور شركات ايام في ابرام عقود
بيع دوليه للنفط الايراني بمائات الملايين
من الدولارات في خلق صارخ للعقوبات
الامريكيه كما رتبت شحنات وساعدت في غسل
اموال العائدات واخفت مصدرا نفط الايراني
لصالح فيلق القدس
واكد البيان ان رجلا الاعمال التركي صدقي
ايام هو من حول العائدات الى فيلق القدس
لتمويل عملياته العقوبات استهدفت ايضا نجل
ايان بهاء الدين اياتنا وشريكه قاسم استاذ
ومواطنين تركيين اخرين على صله بشركاته في
المقابل دافع عن صدقه عن نفسه وفقا من
نشرته رويترز اذا انه شارك في نشاطين
تجاريين مع ايران هما تجاره النفط
والمنتجات البتروليه انتهت بفعل العقوبات
في 2010 بالاضافه الى بيع الكهرباء من
ايران لتركيا بين عامي 2009 و2015 انسحب
منهم مؤخرا بسبب مشاكل في السداد الماليه
صدقي اكد لرويترز ايضا انه لن يسكت على
العقوبات الامريكيه ضد شخصه وشركاته
سندافع عن حقوقنا القانونيه في مواجهه
الجميع عاملته فقط مع المؤسسات الحكوميه
الايرانيه الرسميه لكن يبدو انه هناك
وثائق اخرى تدين ايان كشفت عنها مجله
بوليسيكو الامريكيه تقول فيها وفقا
دبلوماسيين غربيين ان اجتماعا سريا عقد في
بيروت في مارس 2021 حضره مسؤولون عسكريون
وحكوميون ايرانيون ورجال اعمال من تركيا
هدفه الاجتماع كان لت شراكتهما في تهريب
النفط الايراني مجله بوليتيكو اشارت في
تقرير سابق الى ان صدقي هو الشخص الاول في
اكبر شبكه ماليه لفيلق القدس في تركيا في
وقت تواصل فيه واشنطن فرض عقوبات واسعه
النطاق على ايران لتجفيف منابع الارهاب
وتقليص قدرات الحرس الثوري واذرعه